welcome to this video playing Alan Helen
from Norway and I'm trying the english
defence against e46 I had this funny win
a couple of games ago where went for
quicker scholars made and won the Queen
after tables again such set up with d3
yeah come on let's um try to play
actively here 15 I lost years ago I lost
this in a similar fashion as wide and I
couldn't defend my youporn maybe I hope
this is a similar situation here
so maybe curse this one trying to be an
annoyance E&C do
yeah what do we at position
huh have no idea what is going on okay
why didn't lose any material this is
better than in the game that I had two
years ago mmm what is this my do also
could be five this completely out of
this world I come on let's try this i'm
gambling multi-mode moot yeah but i
thought it would be a bit problematic
now for the night maybe an i completely
completely misjudging the stuff e six
coming yeah okay but can play a three or
something or queen f2
each 597 Jack yeah but now air force
it's a problem yeah g3 at the end God g3
the night is strapped can you believe
that I could have just taken could have
just taken on f4 with the night the h5
is just a blunder and I every blunder
Christ what the heck is this 7 pawns can
can try try with a bunch of pawns
maybe with something accurate playoff
chances but it's a very weak hope
I need to really cover this first
otherwise it's completely useless how
many points is that two pawns okay
really this looks like i'm activating
yang a lot here and look at you what all
rights getting its getting very very
interesting again just be 60 this is
three points and activity should i even
i don't think so yeah can do that just
being active with the rooks
look up here and rookie one
hmm I hope this is not too ambitious but
it looks it looks like problems just
this prominently a way this is just mate
yeah sometimes just made if creative
King b3 it's made with the other we emit
and yeah I don't know but this is this a
sir not bad check
h5 and came through g 6 a-2 g5 is a good
position for the king the books cannot
do much here and i have i have also this
move putting putting the sienna in a
really awkward pin just walks III why
not this actually yeah this is good
threatening III now you can three is the
problem ok and now come on it so it's an
exchange yeah this was a very undeserved
victory I hope it's a it's going to be a
victory after I just blundered plundered
this piece
check
silk g3 check
wait yeah very lucky winning yeah I'm
just far too quickly took on it for you
can yeah taking with the night I need to
take with the night or course oops I got
the doorbell ringing okay I need to
answer that thanks for watching